après une première vague dévastatrice
qui a fait des milliers de morts
particulièrement dans les chu celle dé
la situation s'est redressée au québec
très élevé au départ la surmortalité
s'est mise à baisser la sonorité la
différence
celui auquel on n'avait plus atteint en
temps normal de mars 2020 à mars 2022 le
taux de surmortalité s'est établi à 4 et
demi pour cent ce qui représente 6400
personnes décédées de plus que prévu
pendant la même période
quatorze mille deux cents décès
attribués à la coved 19 ont été
apportées au québec
comment expliquer cette différence aux
calculs que des personnes mortes de
l'aco vide aurait rendu leur dernier
souffle d'une façon ou d'une autre
des personnes qui ont été happés par la
kobe était dans les milieux de vie donc
c'était déjà
[Musique]
imminent selon l'étude de l'institut de
la statistique du québec la province se
comparent avantageusement avec son taux
de mortalité de 85 pour ça alors qu'il
est de 6,2 pour ça ailleurs au pays
d'environ 7% en france 11 % au
royaume-uni et 18 % aux etats-unis grâce
aux conseils grâce aux masses grâce à
tous les efforts qu'on a faits sur la
vaccination
on se retrouve que le québec du moins
baissé que dans le reste du canada c'est
aussi au fait comment on organise et les
services les politiques publiques qui
ont été mises l'europe à protéger la
population les plus vulnérables
mais il ne faut pas oublier que les
mesures sanitaires comme les
confinements et des couvre feux ont
aussi eu un impact sur d'autres facteurs
de mortalité les mesures de look down on
contribué à réduire les décès peau des
autres causes mais rejeté par les
accidents par exemple on allait baisser
qui on été causés par la grippe
résultat l'espérance de vie qui avait
baissé de près de 8 mois en 2020 repart
à la hausse elle est maintenant de 83
ans au québec ici olivier bâche un
réseau canada montréal